hello welcome back to hey [ __ ] we
surveyed all of you on our social media
at Tavis you could go follow us over
there we asked you in our stories what
you would like us to talk about that was
non sex related because a lot of our
topics are about sex and grant and we
will still be talking about sex okay
hope you can handle it
but a lot of you wanted to just get
general advice on your life purpose some
of you felt like you were lost do you
like you didn't know if you were doing
the right thing with your life you
didn't know how to do the right thing
with your life you have confidence
issues you're wondering if you've wasted
too much time maybe you feel like you're
you're 25 oh my god you're almost 30 and
you can do [ __ ] with your life yet and
oh my god are you a failure and you know
what calm down take a breath take a deep
deep breath you're gonna do a recount
okay it's okay life is okay life is a
[ __ ] we're gonna make it through it
yeah we're just gonna share a lot of our
personal stories you share anything my
shits pretty sore whatever imperfect
since then we should learn from you the
boss [ __ ] yeah take it away Gio is this
Happ I don't get our life together
[ __ ] they called me on my bluff oh and
we should all introduce ourselves by the
way if you're like something on audio I
am Nikki I'm TIFF I'm Jessica and I'm
Gio your favorite yeah whatever you're
my favorite oh yeah let's talk about
that let's talk about that because I
definitely felt about you being our
favorite yeah yeah my favorite because
you you it seems like even if you don't
have your [ __ ] together you always seem
like you turned it for real
yeah know what I wanted to say cuz I
wanna talk about myself was yeah I was
absolutely lost when I was in my 20s I
thought that there was a set path that
you're supposed to be on you know like
my sister did it she graduated high
school went directly to college and then
she got really good grades and then she
graduated called a psychology graduate
high school went to college graduated
college and then within like two or
three years it was like I married good
job yeah get the house first then you
have the kids a year or two later and I
thought that was the set
everyone does yeah no okay so everyone I
mean that's what I thought but I didn't
follow that at all
yeah me neither me neither yeah so when
I wasn't doing that and I was like oh my
god I'm in school okay
I'm gonna be you know 20 whatever okay I
got it how am I gonna make money to put
a down payment on a house I didn't even
know what a down payment was I didn't
even know what the [ __ ] percentage of
that I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm going off
[ __ ] up and it was really depressing
dude did you or did you always know what
you wanted to do in life I thought I did
okay I thought I did and this is funny
because this is how I picked my major in
college I remember there was and I get C
I don't if you guys remember the Hawaii
gets you thinking oh [ __ ] oh is a test
that test thing you know yes were you
yeah yeah you like say answer a bunch of
questions and then they say you're
cleared and these careers yeah right and
then there was just a set of different
majors that that College offered and I
remember sitting there going [ __ ] I
don't know what I'm gonna do and I
looked at it I'm like well I like
business I guess and I'm like okay well
what's in business and then I looked at
that category Mike Oh marketing I guess
okay that's my major you're actually
really good at business and marketing so
that paid off but I didn't learn [ __ ] at
school okay that wasn't like I would
what is business what is marketing you
know yeah like I remember being in
college university level and being like
okay I'm gonna graduate in like three
quarters because it was a quarter system
and I'm like I have so many options of
marketing like what do i do do I do
analytics do I do print do I do it like
what the [ __ ] and I was so lost yeah I
ended up in a bank I think a lot of
people can relate to this though because
even if your youth you know you you're
in school and you got your major picked
even that's hard to pick you know and
then after yeah because it's like they
tell you for the rest of your life
that's what scares the majority of
people is that if you went to college
you got a major and you graduated
college you want to use what you got
your degree for it was so expensive it
was so expensive and that's what you've
been like learning for the past however
many years and you don't know anything
else yeah so you're like okay now I got
to get a job and then what if you find
out you don't actually like that career
I didn't even get that far cuz I think I
was so intimidated by it that I was just
like well I gotta act like an adult now
I can't make these inappropriate jokes
I'm not gonna
anymore I'm gonna get collared shirts
because I thought that shirts to get
some wide set pants I put in weight
cycling my clothes now yes that's that's
what I wanted because I just that was my
perception of like of business world I
pictured liked if writing checks is what
adults do yes you're just an adult
nimmakur yeah I actually had written
down the idea of this need to become an
adult I think a lot of people feel that
way I think that's a huge trend and when
they feel like they're falling short of
that with oh no I'm supposed to be an
adult but I don't know how to be one I
think that's when people get anxiety and
they feel like they're [ __ ] out
they're not doing the right thing and I
want you to know that most people don't
know what they're doing I actually I
would say all people don't know what
they're doing really ever and of going
along trying to blend it just fit in and
try to find the thing that that keeps us
going the thing that we are passionate
about the thing that drives us you know
that reminds me I recently took a yoga
class and I was in that class and I
asked this woman who she looked like she
knew what the [ __ ] she was doing I was
like um so what do we do like what do we
grab she's like I honestly don't know
I'm copying everyone else so [ __ ]
relatable to life yeah everyone dude I
used to think that everyone like got
born with some memo that or annual that
I didn't get because it felt like
everyone just knew what to do in life
I'll never forget I was in this deli one
time and I wanted to order a sandwich
that's what I wanted I went into a deli
wanting to order a sandwich but I
couldn't just go up to the counter and
order sandwich and then people were
picking up their orders and I just
didn't get it
apparently you have to pick a number but
no one told me this so I was just like
trying to figure out where I go to order
and where what do I do and how are these
people getting food and I felt so stupid
and I
like that's how people can feel in life
where it looks like everyone else is
just like yeah well nobody knows nobody
was like born with it you're all just
you're just kind of learning as you go
and some of us were built with like
parents that taught us certain things
and you kind of go in that direction but
Jess I wanted you to talk about
specifically because I know you said you
were feeling this way recently yeah well
I I almost feel like I've always felt
this way like I looked from the outside
for a period of time like I knew what I
was doing because I got my masters and I
was working and I got you know better
color one way I'll do a Photoshop two
masters yeah yeah so even though going
through all of that and appearing like I
knew what I was doing and I was going in
a direction I always felt kind of empty
and I still to this day some days I wake
up and I'm like what am I even doing you
know you're pissed yeah and I think I've
watched a few videos on that too and I
think a lot of it comes from like as you
get a little bit older to like closer to
30 you start to feel like you start to
understand mortality a little bit more
too and you're like oh eight thirty am i
half way to 60 wait am I gonna die I've
never felt that whatever I okay well
maybe I guess I'm alone in that but I do
get the biological clock thing and
mostly for me it's about kids yeah that
was my that window that you can like
your eggs are gonna be old or gone or
whatever and so I get scared because
like there's so much I want to do in my
career yeah but then I have very limited
time to have kids but then I want to be
there as a mother so I don't want to be
like trying to have split focus so yeah
I do feel anxiety in that regard with
age I think it comes from - like when
you're younger and you think of like 30
and you're like oh by 30 you should be
here and everyone
everyone's like settling on this planet
like what your parents did yeah well
that and then everyone else around you
is completely [ __ ] clueless and they
act like they know what they're doing
and they're also following that same
year and I just the timeline I just
talked about and then you're kind of
comparing yourselves and then it's like
well so-and-so is doing that I should be
doing that do but then without even
thinking does that make that person
happens because I was following that
path getting the corporate job like
wearing the suits and like flying a
different state we all had collared
shirts yeah yeah yeah like I went the
first couple weeks that I had like my
you know corporate uniform on I felt
amazing and then while I was just like
wait this is not making me happy but
it's supposed to so that's when the
whole like life thing like hit me like
what am I supposed to do if this doesn't
make me happy then what am I supposed to
do
yeah and now in this day it's even
harder because you're bombarded with
these images on social media of people
that look like they had their [ __ ]
together and a lot of them are fakers
but you don't know the difference
between who's faking it and who's not
and so you're just feeling less and less
like man I really am a loser I really
don't have my [ __ ] together yeah and I
think what like for me the best advice I
could give is is focusing on the sun's
like cliche but focusing on yourself
self-discovery is a wonderful thing
because that's gonna guide you to what
your purpose is how do you do that cuz I
hear that a lot like I'm just trying to
find myself and stuff like how do you
how do you go about that being alone a
lot like letting yourself be alone
letting yourself find what actually
gives you that tingling sensation of
like joy and excitement you know like
when you're a kid and you're like it's
Christmas Eve and you can't wait for
[ __ ] Christmas morning you know that
tingling of like I can't wait to open
those presents and you're like
visualizing yourself opening presents
and all the toys you're gonna get
there's stuff out there for you that
makes you feel that way and you just
have to be patient enough to find it and
like give yourself that time to actually
explore what that could be and I think a
lot of people are so busy doing the
things that they think they're supposed
to be doing like well I gotta pay the
bills and I got to go to work and they
all survival
yes survival stuff and so they have so
much fear that
if they if they even pause for like an
hour of their day to do self-discovery
that somehow it's gonna throw them off
the path when really it's the opposite
it's gonna guide you towards your path
and like I guess I had the benefit of
not having friends so I spent a lot of
time alone back in the Danny's for but
we're getting really close to the mic on
that one so that we can all land really
well but yeah I think that being single
that's another one a lot of people rely
on relationships to make them happy and
and that's how you get into toxic
unhealthy relationships is that person
makes you really really happy in the
beginning and then it's just like a
really fleeting feeling because it's not
you haven't found your own source of
happiness you have to really work on
building your own source of happiness
that you can refill on your own before
having someone else just enhance that
and a lot of people don't take the time
to do that and they're stuck in a job
they hate because they don't actually
know what makes them happy yeah I could
definitely relate to that so is I've
been in survival mode for pretty much my
whole life until I met JK and then
that's when I was able to not be in the
hospital scene anymore and be like oh
you know what this makes me happy to not
clock in and clock out every day yeah
and get to have fun with my friends but
then it also brought me into the space
of like well I'm not focusing on just
surviving anymore actually have the
luxury of like thinking about what makes
me happy and then that scared me
yeah or why does it scare you guys well
I'll tell you right after we talk about
door - because you know what y'all need
sangdong I mean at your door if you're
going to eat and survive yes you've got
a long day at work a tough day at school
you suck in the office I love it no I'm
so happy to be alive in this day and age
because like I live off of door - like I
love that I just get on my phone get on
that app and I have like the world of
restaurants on my fingertips because I'm
like right now I want some sushi but I
also want some fresh juices like hell
yeah I can have both from different
places delivered to my doorstep why the
hell would I not do this yeah it's
absolutely beautiful I like that it's
easy because I am supposed to cook my
meals I'm on like a diet where you're
supposed to like cook your meals and
stuff
but then when I look online and I look
on door - and there's a restaurant that
cooks the same exact meal I'm supposed
to cook I just would rather have someone
else cook it they have over three
hundred and ten thousand amazing
restaurants on there like you are always
gonna find something that you're craving
or the F sure I don't know if we can
cause so I'm just gonna keep it out so
yeah so if you're a busy mom a busy dad
or you're on the go or you forgot
someone's birthday I've done this so
many times where I'm like oh my god it's
someone's birthday let me send them a
cake and I door - that Wow it's a bottle
of wine we do that that on our last
episode yeah if you guys can find the
video where we got through but yeah you
guys right now our listeners get five
dollars off their first order 15 bucks
15 bucks come on that's really easy or
more when you download the door - app
and enter code b-tch that's five dollars
off your first order when you download
the door - app form from that form from
the app store and enter promo code BTC
again that promo code alright you guys
are listening so that's five dollars off
your first order from door - okay
so we were surviving all right hmm now
that you're passing by though let's find
your purpose what makes me I think what
we were talking about was like once me
antov yeah they both experience the
whole like Oh get out of survival mode
get out of this job that we hate and we
have all this free time with our
beautiful friends that let us work with
them we are very much guys but then it
also brought in a sense of like oh
there's this vacuum now and it's like
well what now I have to fill in my whole
life and figure it out with what valium
what would it mean to Becky there's like
myth of stability yeah in corporate jobs
that I see by saying that corporate
world you're leaving the stable life
yeah yeah now you're in this like
unstable like you gotta figure out fend
for yourself yeah well you're like
vatican's right only yeah you are it is
different
because now you're happier but like you
have this knot in your stomach type of
feeling about now it's all on me yeah
make it happy but or not but but really
there is no stability anywhere like
stability is such a myth maybe back in
the back in the way back day is when you
had a pension and like one person's
income could feed the whole family and
buy a house and stuff maybe there was a
little bit of stability for that
person's lifetime but it's that is long
gone that is no longer a theme but yet
we're still operating out of that
mindset because that's what we were
taught from the beginning so I get how
you would be fearful happy well it's not
even just about the stability too it's
about well now I have all this free time
I should be able to do everything that I
thought the job is holding me back from
yeah actually be happy but now I find
myself a lot of times too I was like
okay well I have extra free time I am
working on stuff but also should I be
working more towards the career part or
should I just be working more towards
like what's the daily thing that makes
me happy or like what makes me happy
beyond this like is I mean is this even
going to be prominent so what really is
my life and what is it supposed to look
like and yeah I still don't know I think
that's actually pretty cool in a cool
position to kind of be in right because
it's like now you have all these options
and I know that can be definitely
overwhelming depending on you know how
how you view it but then I think that's
the only way kind of going back to what
Nicky was saying where you can find out
who you are what you're kind of made of
mm-hm so so yeah dabbled in this and see
if this makes you happy for like damn is
there more out there then I feel like
you should go check that out like you
should answer that I think for me
personally the thing that holds me back
is the fear of failure even if it's
something fun like if it's just like hey
let me just buy some paint and a canvas
and let me paint this I am [ __ ]
scared of making a horrible painting I
don't know why you're alone that really
holds me back from trying to find the
thing that I really love see for you
TIFF I feel like your job right now
should be to go out and fail as much as
you can
I think every day you should find a new
thing to fail at you go pick up some
paints and paint a flower or whatever
you try to make it and just fail and you
would be surprised at how much you
succeed at and I think through doing
that you would
and what makes you happy you would find
what you're good at that also fulfills
you in that way and then you kind of
just follow that sort of path and I feel
like not feel like failure holds a lot
of people back yeah yeah I think for me
um what has helped me a lot I've never
been a person to be kind of super
over-analytical I guess hmm is that even
yeah mom that like I've always just kind
of found myself going with the flow like
I've felt that I've made just decent
judgement calls when it came to the
people that I hung out with I I don't
even know if I did this on purpose but I
just always was around really good
people was where I was around what the
[ __ ] is like a whole thing of Red Bull
and I'm like all over the place
they don't be afraid to talk you'd like
fail no but I've always put myself in
really cool circles with really
inspirational people that like just kind
of I felt like would have my back so um
it was just easy for me to go like well
let me see what they're doing and I kind
of look at that and I'm like that looks
kind of like fun let me try that and
then I never had a failure or succeed
mode in my head that I was like
constantly trying to hit I was just like
until this day I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing but I just know that I
want to be happy yeah and sometimes that
happiness is short and it's and it can
be fleeting sometimes it's more
long-term but I'm just constantly
seeking just happiness whether that's
like I want in and out right now cuz I'm
gonna be I mean that's kind of impulsive
but like I just want to be happy about
that
and then the pressure off of yourself
yeah I feel like you know so I think
that's a big thing is that some people
can relieve themselves of that pressure
to like oh this is happiness or this
maybe or this is not like you just kind
of like just take it day by day and like
yeah I mean that's cuz because like
we've said already here like nothing is
really promised there's no stability
like anything can falter like anything
can fail anything can crash and burn
right now at this very moment like we
think we're safe here but a plane could
come crashing in and and it's the most
ironic thing and we die right now
and yeah how do we how do we prepare for
that you really can't know the only
thing you can just kind of control is
just how you view it and how you feel
about it and then just constantly trying
to like be like chase that happiness
yeah that actually changed my whole
mindset because I don't know I've always
been in between I was raised like soup
like disciplines very important
responsibilities very important you have
a responsibility to pay your bills on
time and do all this stuff and then I've
also been told like to follow your
passions and all this you know and and
sometimes you get caught in the middle
where you're like am i doing the right
thing because I'm Paulette following my
passion then maybe I'm letting my
responsibilities down or whatever but
hearing somebody say like you were only
on this planet for like 80 something
years maybe more if you're lucky but
that's such a short amount of time for
the grand scheme of things of how how
long the earth is here how they like
long the universe has been around you
get this gift of life for 80 years
yeah it's meant for you to live it it's
meant for you to go out and fail and and
figure things out and have fun and
follow your joy and also you know learn
how to be responsible but do it while
you're not at the sacrifice of living
yeah or hurting other people I even
think the word passion is very
intimidating yeah you like to be like
this this fire within you where it's
like it's this one time that you're
gonna feel this passion and you have
like to commit to it but even for me I'm
like I don't know if I feel that passion
for things I think for me I'm just like
this is [ __ ] fun no see I like have
fun for fun I think people will get
locked on this idea that finding your
passion it's one thing yeah it's not one
day finding your passion is finding a
passion that like that's something that
you can get you can get passionate about
yeah finding that like the feeling of
passion yeah your own people don't feel
that at all though for for anything yeah
maybe the way to start is just like what
do I hate the least and I can spend a
little bit more time in that but that
also could just be a byproduct of
depression or something like that like I
shake it you can't get passionate about
anything you're just like well this part
of my day was less bad than that part so
maybe I can try to do more of the
well I think if you're if you're in that
headspace though then it has to come to
one where it's like okay I gotta erase
everything that's outside of me right
now this whole passion [ __ ] whatever
like let me not think about that anymore
let me think about myself what do I want
out of me do I want me to think ten
positive things today well let's work on
that
do I want me to have a six-pack well
let's work on that do I want to have
better connections with friends with
family like you just set little things
for yourself
and then the passion soul and all that
[ __ ] that can come later mm-hmm
I also just let myself be open to all
the cheesiness and try not to judge like
those I guess self-help type of books
personal development books and those
books a lot like if you read them on the
daily basis it just really helps to
shift your perspective every day and
gives you like something to think about
throughout the day that maybe you
wouldn't have thought about before
and I have found just by being open to
it and being like okay I think this is
cheesy but I'll try it for 30 days yeah
that my perspective on things would
totally shift I was getting being
grateful for a lot more things than I
was grateful for before where I knew
logically I was grateful for things like
I'm yeah I'm grateful to have a roof
over my head I'm grateful for my family
whatever but I didn't feel it like I
wasn't like feeling it in my body in a
way that like makes me truly want to
give back to the world and I think that
to me is the finding your passion is to
find being so grateful and then being
wanting to work out of service and like
what kind of service would you want to
do that would fulfill you if that makes
sense and so like for me like helping
people really fills me now whereas
before I was like how do I get mine like
how do I make money for me to live you
know and now it's like how do I help
other people maybe four completely lost
and completely like don't care about
anything maybe just think of some sort
of noble thing like well what would I
like to do to help someone even in the
tiniest way is that what you do
sometimes I think like oh if I can't be
happy with what I'm doing today can I at
least like make Joe happy by like making
him a meal and I just start there like
and it's it's not a life purpose or
anything like that but it's just like
sometimes people and a lot of our
listeners probably are to the
where they're like I don't even know how
to make tomorrow a good day yeah how do
I even start there and so that's just
some it's something I'm still even
working on to like I told I told geo the
other day too I was like I don't even
know if I care about what happiness is I
was and she was like oh that's okay yeah
I was just like people are like people
are like Oh find your happiness but I'm
like happiness seems pointless like why
do I care about happiness like what's
useless what is you know like what is
this this point of life of like just
happiness like is it just self
gratification or what what is it you
know and why do you how do you what is
the definition of happiness for you um I
feel like it's like a lot of smiles and
rainbows and like everyone's high-fiving
wonder that that sounds very like fake
yeah anyone that's like you know yeah I
think um if you really want to go into
just there's different frequencies and
energies right and like I'm not gonna
get super moves down Nikki's yeah but no
but scientifically we are all made of
energy and all are vibrating like this
tables vibrating at a certain level this
right now you're at a higher energy you
can see redbull colligative geo so like
their happiness is at a different
frequency then sadness and lower
frequency emotions like anger and stuff
and when you're at a lower frequency
emotion you tend to gravitate towards
other lower frequency things misery
loves company yeah yeah that's why I
like me and TIFF like very low energy
very sad I mean what it does is it just
confirms why you should feel sad or mad
because you'll just find more things to
feel sad or mad about and it's not that
those things don't exist it's that that
is on the plane that you're at like
that's all you see a vibrational I know
what's a trip with me though if I'm
around everyone that's like way up here
I immediately do the opposite like today
like I actually feel pretty good but for
some reason my energy and I feel it and
I'm trying to fight it it's like way the
[ __ ] down here and I'm like why I don't
know why it could be also you getting
grounded you know there's there's I
don't know what you're feeling inside so
I can't really say but sometimes like a
feeling of emptiness that's a good
grounded place to start from but you
should I guess take the time to get in
tune with your own self because you
should be able to differentiate between
different emotions like emptiness
sadness anger and I think that people
are just so scared of emotions sometimes
where they're scared to like embrace or
really look into it that they just shove
all of the options down I think every
time I feel the emptiness feeling I'm
like oh no I can't feel this I shouldn't
be feeling this so I need to hide it or
push it away or do something else fill
it with some I don't think you can't
feel it well I think most people don't
want to sit around and feel emptiness
like you and you see other people being
happy so you're like well I shouldn't
feel emptiness but I think something I'm
starting to realize is that you're gonna
have moments of emptiness and you can
just kind of sit through it and like
accept it and then eventually because
nothing's permanent like we said but at
the time everything feels permanent when
you're going through it so even if it's
just today I just feel complete
emptiness I probably won't tomorrow and
if I'm okay with knowing that I probably
won't feel that tomorrow or maybe I'll
feel it for two weeks or maybe I'll feel
it for two months but it's not going to
be forever it's okay to just be just to
sit with my emptiness and be okay with
it
that's a huge thing like being okay with
it like yeah being accepting where
you're at now as a starting point for
you what was the point where you're like
oh wait I can deal with this like where
did where did that turning point happen
I think I just when I feel lost I tend
to do like a lot of like youTube
searches I'm like oh empty or like Oh
existential crisis or midlife crisis or
whatever like I start looking up stuff
and I listen to people talk I want to
see your search it's like it's like how
not to destroy your life - yeah yeah I
do not throw everything out the window
no so I and I hear talks and people are
just like just reminding us like the
same we're kind of doing now like
reminding each other that nothing is
permanent and everything's okay and get
through it you can go to therapy you can
talk to other people other adults that
you think that they know
doing and they'll reassure you they
don't know either like not everything's
great every everyday things aren't
hunky-dory 24/7 you just it's a change
of perspective which is something that I
have to still work a lot on is just
changing perspective it's just choosing
to not feel like it's forever yeah where
are you at now um I don't know how to
describe it I think I'm like well
because you know you guys know I went
through the whole thing with my mom
passing earlier this year and I think
immediately after that happened I just
jumped right back into everything like I
was I took like a week or two of being
sad or whatever and I was like oh no
like her death gave me a boost of life
like oh I have to live my life it's
gonna be amazing now because like she
didn't get to she lost her life really
I'm just gonna run out there like hit
the ground running and like do
everything that I've been holding myself
back on so I did that for a little while
and then time rolls around and it's kind
of like oh wait a lot of things about
processing with grief and all that stuff
is still hitting me but I still have to
maintain work and all of these things
and it feels like a scary point to be in
and I'm lucky that I have friends that I
can think that I can call and like other
things that I can listen to and read and
I listen to Eckhart Tolle oh yeah my
kids like his talks his reading is very
hard to read like very dense the books
are very dense but if you just listen to
his speeches a lot of times they call me
down because I get so lost in my mind
and in my thoughts and then when he
talks it he helps you kind of realize
that you're not just your thoughts like
you're also like a kind of a
consciousness behind those thoughts and
if you can separate yourself from these
like crazy wormholes you get yourself
into then you can kind of find some
calmness and some peace to deal with
whatever you're dealing with and that's
exactly that's exactly what I was
talking about with the like reading
Eckhart Tolle if you like him you
probably would like Wayne Dyer to those
types of books just have either
listening to them with audiobook or
reading them it's a perspective shift
yeah Moli over time you're changing the
way you view life and eventually it
raises vibration vibrationally it
attracts your you're gonna attract more
happiness and like higher vibrational
emotions and that actually is more of
what happiness is then like us
high-fiving and like yeah yeah and with
diamonds and fur coats of [ __ ]
you know it's like it's just feeling
content in within yourself and and the
like appreciating the beauty of life and
yeah even like the sadness part the sad
parts of it is like appreciate it you
know I recently went through that whole
perspective shift thing they you guys
know about being a machines but like I
don't tell me more about the behind the
scenes behind a scene ya know cuz well
to fill you guys in it's uh Casey and I
went through this crazy transformational
like letting go of all the heavy weight
in our relationship or seven-year
relationship and we just kind of found
like a new chapter and so I was feeling
[ __ ] amazing for that one week after
to me like one or two weeks or I
literally felt like I saw the world in a
whole new different light like a rebirth
yeah I legit felt like I was reborn and
I just felt so happy and so calm and so
content and I just everything was like I
was viewing the world with rose-colored
glasses on the table and but I don't
know what happened and like about two
weeks after that which has been about a
month and a half now I haven't felt that
anymore and I don't know where it went
and I'm just kind of like not
necessarily back to square one cuz that
was a really dark dark place that I was
before but now I'm not that bad but now
I'm not as good as I once was like no
one is happy like they're all the time
24/7 like you have dips in anything and
I think it's just you know allowing
yourself to feel ya what you feel but
knowing that you you're in control more
than you are in control I think you're
able to like yeah I think the beautiful
thing about that is is knowing that
you're never really supposed to be there
because you're not gonna grow from that
like imagine if everything's [ __ ]
what is it Truman Show yeah it's like
you're gonna [ __ ] go miserable I
think it's when you have your down times
that you're like okay wait a minute I
got too complacent everything's too
simple like now I got a [ __ ] lesson
to learn yeah and I think that's when
you you kind of dig yourself out of the
dirt trenches again and you're like okay
cool like I'm back up here again and
it's literally like this like all the
fun down up and yeah all this I thing
for me though it's been like
mainly down here like literally my whole
life
it had like some peaks here and there
like you know Isaac was born or like you
know getting engaged like these little
Peaks but from that one week like one
two weeks I was so up like so high like
I've never been that high up before
where I kind of got scary where I'm like
whoa wait how long is this gonna last
yeah yeah this a major event happened
you know and so emotions are always
going to be heightened and I feel like
it's totally normal and a lot of people
if like I need something to like look
forward to like they're not happy with
the day-to-day yeah then it's like oh we
got three-day weekend coming up oh we're
gonna go to Big Bear or whatever and
then the whole week they're looking
forward to going to Big Bear instead of
like being in the in the moment and
being present and appreciating like what
is whatever is happening there and
finding a way to like I feel like you
have to find a way to balance that out
you know and not live for just this
weekend because those moments are always
fleeting it's always gone and then it's
just like what you're so the most of
your life is supposed to be [ __ ] except
for these like little moments of
happiness no so that's I think that
allowing yourself to figure out what can
consistently like get you there where
you're not like looking forward to just
one thing out of the year or the month
or whatever that's hard because like we
spend most of our lives like searching
for goals or like trying to get to a
certain goal but it's like and I've know
this for sure like as soon as I get what
I want it's no longer important to me it
doesn't matter anymore it doesn't feel
good anymore now I need to find the next
thing yeah what's the next thing that's
gonna you know motivate me to actually
wake up every day and what is there is
there something wrong with that no but I
think it's when you get saddened every
time that you do reach that goal and
realize that the the fulfillment you
expected it to have doesn't necessarily
come like and you didn't take advantage
of the feeling of getting to the goal
hmm
so I spend most of the time breezing
through to hurry up and try to get there
but once I get it it's like okay and
then now I have got nothing to look
forward to and then the sadness comes
back in so it's like how do I appreciate
all the days it takes to get there and
even once I get it like okay that's
great but what's the next thing I can do
because I'm looking forward to the
sense of getting to it not just getting
to it totally and we will talk about
that right after this break
ooh so we just want to give a shout out
today to our sponsor article article if
you didn't know is a furniture company
they make such a cute like awesome
furniture I have actually followed their
account for some years now and they do
mid-century modern with a Scandinavian
touch type of furniture totally my vibe
what I really like is they have a small
footprint so if you have like smaller
square footage in your house you're like
oh well how do I make my living room
look nice and big without having big
pieces of furniture they do really cool
unique designs like that yeah it's the
easiest way to buy beautiful modern
furniture because you just order online
through a lot on that order and they cut
out the middleman so they're able to
keep the prices lower yeah all of their
warehouses are here in the US and you
don't have to do they don't have like a
showroom or anything like that they
don't have any salespeople trying to
upsell you on anything you're saving
like 30% yes off of the price you're
saving cause of all that 30% yes exactly
off of traditional prices the quality is
amazing so I got a bed frame and it's
from Oakwood and it's like solid wood
and usually when you my solid wood
pieces that I worked up a lot yeah I was
able to buy this bedroom I believe was
under $400 Wow which is an amazing it is
it is a bed frame and the shipping was
easy everything came with in they have
like a three week guarantee so like
everything comes really fast which I
don't know if you have are ordered
furniture online but sometimes if you
order it it can take up to two months
yeah it's look from my dining table
again it's a nightmare and then you're
like just the whole time not having a
table and you can't have a temporary
table because your tables coming in
ridiculous so they have like really fast
shipping and if and it's 30-day return
policy with some more returns and
exchanges
yeah they set it up for you so if you do
get something and you didn't really like
it they are able to do that but article
is offering our listeners $50 off their
first purchase of $100 or more to claim
visit vertical comm / b-tch go to
article comm slash b tch and the
discount will be automatically applied
at check out
that's article comm slash b tch to get
$50
your first purchase of $100 more more
nice hey I was reading somewhere and I
can't remember the book I was reading I
feel like it was either subtle art of
not giving a [ __ ] by my Cranston or his
other book everything in spots those
books are both really really great
definitely check them out if you have it
totally has a it always shifts my
perspective reading a chapter from those
books but he was talking about I think
it was a latest book about how we don't
actually get happiness from the
achievement of our goals like everyone
thinks like oh once I achieve this goal
I'll be happy we actually get happiness
out of having problems and finding the
solution to our problems
yeah it's just that as we progress
through life we want to have better
problems so our problems get better like
a you know rich guys problems are
different than like homeless guys
problems yeah but they still have
problems and you're never gonna be
problem free and you don't want to be
because actually you're dead yeah it's
still you won't live anywhere you're
just not
that's why rich as people are [ __ ]
donkeys but they've reached the success
of [ __ ] all like the hot people that
were like they're actually [ __ ] the
wrong place that's are they sleep with
donkeys oh okay yes yeah they need the
next 10 drugs yeah yeah yeah I mean I
mean you touched on it already
Jess or Nicky touched on it for you
words you just you have to feel it in
the moment like you have to be in it you
know you can say like as soon as you
start feeling some sort of hardship or
whatever you're like I'll deal with it
later I just got to focus on this goal
yeah yeah whatever whatever and you're
kind of sweeping it on the rug mm-hmm
but I think there's so many [ __ ]
lessons to be learned in that you know
like why the [ __ ] can I not understand
this or whatever
yeah I've recently probably within the
past year every time I feel a feeling
because you are the stories that you
tell yourself and so if you've been
telling yourself the same
same stories year after year after year
and wonder why you're still in the same
place well that's why and so four
different things that I feel like I've
tried to like certain character traits I
don't like about myself that I'm I know
logically I don't want to have them yet
they still keep coming up yeah
when I catch myself having one of those
thoughts and I know I want to stop it I
try to think of five different ways to
think about it like oh cool I have
different new ways to think about it
instead and I've slowly started
replacing my thoughts and therefore
replacing my stories and changing those
habits whereas before I thought I could
never change those habits or what's an
example with about okay so I'm like how
do you compare myself on social media
it's a negative trait that I know
logically you shouldn't compare yourself
on social media but I can't help it like
everything when I scroll past and I see
people looking like they're like like
for example I've been acting for most of
my life and taking it professionally
like when the professional route for the
past 12 years and I feel like I was
supposed to a book to show by 20 foot
where I was supposed to be there by now
right
and my career ahead has shifted but for
a while I was feeling like a failure and
whenever I would see someone new that
had just started acting maybe like three
four five years ago and they're already
like booking shows or being a series
regular I couldn't help but feel like
really jealous even though I want it to
be happy for them even it was like a
friend like that I was rooting for them
I was happy for them
in this sense but over here I was still
feeling like it added to my sense of
feeling like a failure
and so that had to stop because I
couldn't even watch the Oscars anymore
because I was so reminded of just how I
would never get there and laugh and I
don't even want an Oscar but it's just
like the that just whole life in there
he had that visual of success right yeah
and I just felt like so I mean II feel
so low but it wasn't that making me feel
though it was the stories I was telling
myself that me feel that way and so I
started correcting that behavior by when
I would catch myself feeling a certain
way just being really aware like getting
in tune with that and being aware of it
replacing it with a like good for them
or like you know congratulatory things
and then if that didn't work I would
replace it with what do I want to do
next I was like oh that's cool they got
to do this we don't what do I want to do
next or shipping it towards a more goal
based type of thing
switching it to instead of envy letting
it be inspiring which had always been
really hard for me before but just
trying to find something that I could
take as inspiration from the thing I was
getting triggered by and it really did
help to curb all of that and I think I
realized through doing that that I don't
even really want a TV show anyway it was
the idea of having a TV show yeah
because it meant something yeah and
that's what I mean but everyone being
like who what actually makes you happy
because the idea of what would make you
happy
because I found that what actually makes
me happy is connecting to people through
a large platform and that's what I would
have been doing as a character on a show
I thought but instead I'm doing it on
YouTube on my own platform and through
different shows and like you know this
podcast and other podcasts and and
that's actually the feeling I wanted a
way more kind of worthwhile because
you're actually interacting with these
people instead of just being a character
on a show who's so far removed from
their audience like usually you know as
a youtuber or whatever like you're
actually seeing them like in your
comments and you're responding to those
comments and you're talking about things
that you can hear that they care about
whereas it just a TV show characters not
ah and you're only seen the good when
you're envious when I when I stopped
doing that I was like oh actually a lot
of my friends were complaining that
their shows get cancelled within two
episodes you get all the way to like
filming the pilot and that won't even
get released or they go for like a year
and they bought a new house and now the
show gets cancelled and they can't pay
for the house anymore and it's like wow
I didn't even think of all of that how
when you're on a show you're working for
someone else or is like when you're
creating your own content you're in
control of that like for better or for
worse you're in control of it yeah yeah
we were in the wrong vibrations girl
yeah yeah it really was and but it you
have to be self aware of it like well
justify it I was like yeah I should feel
like a failure like right now cuz I I
put in a lot of work but I'm not getting
the same thing so I should feel like a
failure yeah because I am a failure and
it was just the story I kept telling
myself yeah TIFF actually taught me that
I did yeah like well I kind of took this
for me but you you were going to therapy
and your therapist was like well what's
the voice
in your head yeah you know and it's it's
literally what you're telling yourself
and then kind of that's kind of a really
good start to just hear what how you're
talking to yourself and that was some
huge that I didn't even know um luckily
I was I had gone through so much [ __ ]
that I was telling myself at least like
level-headed [ __ ] where I wasn't like
you're a piece of [ __ ] I wasn't like
you're so perfect you're the best but I
was like whoa I never really thought how
impactful that is that is also true cuz
just recently I've been trying to get
more active and there was this one day
room I had booked a class for the next
day and I was just like I don't want to
go I don't want to go my head my head
voice my inner voice was just like go
you don't have to go it's okay you don't
have to you could just it's fine and
then I noticed that voice in my head and
I was like wait hold on no a girl you
got this you got this let's go you're
gonna wake up in the morning you're
gonna feel great gonna have your coffee
and all this stuff and then I ended up
doing it I'm like whoa-ho that voice is
so powerful really yeah yeah
my therapist when I was going through
this she told me one thing that really
helps me a lot
maybe it would help some of you but she
I was telling her after she like learned
about my life and everything and how I
felt like I was a failure and we already
had discovered that I learned that I get
love when I achieve things that how I
learned to be loved and so I felt like I
was not worth loving she actually gave
me this picture and she was like okay
let's just scrap all that let's pretend
you get to choose your life let's
pretend like reincarnation is real and
you before coming down here you got to
choose your life and you got to see you
picked out this picture and you're like
okay I want to live in Los Angeles by
the beach I want a husband that really
loves me and like it's really funny and
like I want to be able to talk to lots
of people but I want to be able to just
be myself and like I want to do that and
let's pretend that you could picked all
of that are you happy with what you
picked and I'm like yeah I guess like
looking at that as a picture from as an
outsider yeah I would be really happy
with that
and that really like made me appreciate
what I had and this was before I had
done a lot of the stuff that I have now
this was like three years ago and it
really gave me the like motivation again
to be like I have a really good life now
just add to it it's like instead of [ __ ]
how am I gonna save myself from this
[ __ ] life that I created it was like no
like everything's actually this is great
let's just add to it mm-hmm
yeah making small changes to shift the
things you don't like maybe yeah and
there I think that everyone can do that
exercise I think there's everyone has
stuff in their life that to an outsider
is like whoa you have that that's crazy
like no chance yassem but you just have
a hard time seeing oh we are in it yeah
yeah I mean that business kind of works
the same way where if you're so looking
at you know the day-to-day stuff it's so
easy for you to forget you know how
great you're doing or the bigger picture
because it's like you're just so in the
[ __ ] that all you see are negative
things you're like look I'm never gonna
grow this is never gonna change I'm not
gonna get any better
how am I gonna survive because it's like
you're only looking and solving these
small problems where if like you said
you pull back and then you look at the
grand scheme of things you're like oh
[ __ ] this is actually not that bad and I
can definitely add a lot more to it
mm-hmm
is that what helped you guys or
particularly I guess yugioh when you
left your bank job and you started doing
more entrepreneurial stuff if what
helped it like doing that picture things
yeah I didn't do that man like I think I
was too stupid and I think that worked
in my favor where I didn't understand
the consequences of things and all I did
was I looked at what I needed to live
you know they live the lifestyle that I
had like very like minimally like bare
minimum style I just looked at what I
needed to survive in that regard and
then I was just like I think I'm gonna
do it and so I don't know if I'm the
best person cuz I just didn't think of
repercussions I didn't think of like
what my parents gonna say with like
you're like leap and the net will cut
you tap yeah I was just like [ __ ] it
like if I like what's the worst that can
happen and I just kind of just jumped
into the pool you know so I don't know
if I'm really good but I think it's cuz
I was dumb like I didn't know what was I
don't think it's dumb I was yeah okay
not like smart date tonight naivete yeah
yeah I just think it was because I was
so sheltered that one I was just a
[ __ ] animal that was caged up that
just needed to just fly and the other
one was I didn't know like I wasn't
taught like these are the consequences
yeah but I think so
times PB go too hard in the other
direction where like I was just warned
about so many consequences that when I
made the decision to drop out of college
to pursue acting it was met with a lot
of like resistance yeah resistance
because of how it would you know like oh
now you don't have a back-up plan and
all this stuff but I just felt like if I
spent too much time focusing on Plan B
that I wouldn't achieve plan a and I
think that helped a lot I don't know
like I I just think for me a lot of the
best choices I've made have been with my
gut and name as long as I knew the logic
like okay just know that this is the
worst that could happen yeah and I
decided to do it anyway cuz I felt it
was right it's same here it's paid off
but I don't know if that's martyred um I
don't know if that's something everybody
should follow I just think that I just
think that your intuition
everyone has intuition and it the more
that you usually like that first thought
that comes into your mind like if you're
gonna go if you see like an alley versus
a well-lit street right you just look at
and you're like oh that looks bad
talking and thinking about it you're
like well I shouldn't judge the
darkstrike make the stupid mistakes but
if it is your first thought like even if
you're buying something simple as like
an outfit right and you're like man
those pants are ugly as [ __ ] but then
you really look at you're like what do I
mean Willie well let me just try it on
let me see then you're making the wrong
decision like now I've learned at 35
that it's like the first thought I'm
just going to bring you joy does enough
for you joy oh no got it right oh yeah
true if it's like if it's like I like it
cool then I went with that but if I'm
you know what I mean like I know as soon
as I start thinking about too many
options and I start trying to justify
[ __ ] and I'm like I usually make the
wrong decision it's just like my gut
that tells me like yep that I'm going
with that yeah I think that's great
advice because for me too I think it's
maybe like the the stereotypical
pressures of like you should look at all
your options you should think about it
and this is how you make an educator who
said that though society I don't know
any society killing it at life I always
look at that yeah if you're giving me
advice I'm like well what have you
accomplished let me see you might not
[ __ ] you is what you're saying is
[ __ ] dope ass advice because I look
up to you a lot and so I've been and
then also the Marie Kondo thing that
I've done recently like I cleaned out my
whole closet and then just doing that
intuition like that first gut feeling oh
she said that yes yeah that's ours a
like you're killing it cuz like that is
such great advice like really just go
with your gut and what really makes you
happy in that moment like what sparks
joy yeah that's so you're smarter than
you think man like everyone is smarter
than they give themselves credit and I
also think that when I don't know if
this is true for yugioh but like when
you take a big risk like dropping out of
college or quitting like a stable job
just like there's a lot of people that
are logical minded that will try to they
want to help you and warn you and keep
you safe and and it's just like they
give you kind a lot of hate for it and
so it makes you second-guess yourself
but I I think that I think that that's
what stops a lot of people from doing it
cuz you're listening to all those people
but what you said only listen to people
that you admire them and like one you
want their life that's otherwise yeah
you're gonna fall into that trap like
when my parents were like you don't want
to move out cuz this is gonna happen is
gonna happen I'm like but you guys don't
seem that happy I'm moving happened to
me like my boss from my old job in back
in San Antonio I was there for like four
years he texted me recently so he's
still thinking about me but he was just
like are you still making YouTube videos
damn he opened with that and I was like
actually yeah I am and he was like well
if you want a real job you can come back
and all that says all this stuff to me
you know but I'm like and I'm like well
I'm glad that I have Plan B but also I
was thinking about it I was like if he's
still thinking about me four years later
he must be bored and you must have
really shitty employees that he can't
find good you be still yeah you were
saying that everyone was telling you
like don't like get out of this
situation well yeah that was my manager
yeah but this was the owner this is one
of the owners of the company he was just
like oh you still making still youtube
videos I'm like well what are you doing
are you still writing your signature on
the on the same audit every 52 weeks you
know like there you go what's the
difference like do I really want to be
in your shoes like mmm you know even if
he owns part of this company and he
feels like he has prestige it's got to
be boring as [ __ ] and he's been doing it
for 50 years and like do I care that now
my past owner
of a company which is making fun of me
for making YouTube videos like this
initially it burns right cuz I'm like oh
that is like what do people think of me
and then I'm like actually I mean I get
to kind of sleep in make my own schedule
like work with friends like I'm not
doing the same [ __ ] all the time so yeah
it's fine like you have it in you yeah
like you have that mentality in you and
now it's just kind of like exercising
that muscle in Konya repeating what
you're telling yeah cuz a lot of times I
let myself have those thoughts of like
that am I still making silly Tube videos
you know like but then at the end of the
day it's bigger than that it's more than
that it's also my life and like I can it
can go in 15 different directions like
this it doesn't have to be it it can be
something else and I think what you were
saying earlier too about looking at
worst-case scenario that's always helped
it's like yeah at the end of the day if
I flop on my face what's the worst thing
that can happen and there's always like
50 levels before it goes to I'm sleeping
in the streets yeah you know so like
there's not then that's not gonna happen
ya know yeah it's it's great advice and
and it's nothing is permanent like the
only thing I've even tell my mom my
mom's like early she's about to hit 70
and I'm like she's so fearful of
everything in life mm-hmm but I'm like
the only thing that you have guaranteed
in this life right now is the fact that
you're gonna die one day like that's the
only thing that's [ __ ] guaranteed
everything else who [ __ ] cares yeah I
think my mom too like I feel like my
mom's biggest thing is she thinks she's
too old to start over and a lot of
people feel that way a lot of people
feel like they're too old but they're
always gonna feel too old 10 years to 10
years from now you're gonna feel like
you're too old but 10 years is gonna
pass no matter what so wouldn't you
rather have been working on something
that you're really happy with for 10
years and they're really far in just 2
years of trying something different and
if you don't know what it is that's
making you happy you have 10 years to
figure out exactly that being said thank
you so much for listening today - hey
[ __ ] podcast be sure to subscribe on
YouTube be sure to rate us on iTunes we
really appreciate it
and if you could like our videos it
really helps our channel out you can
also follow us on Instagram we've been
posting a lot more we get
topic ideas from you guys on our stories
like I mentioned earlier and thank you
to our sponsor door - and article yes
thank you bye-bye bad I did J later